so we're here today at collector mania
how are you enjoying the event so far
Glenn it's interesting it so you meet so
many different types of people come
along and their interest you know their
passions is great you know you get that
energy from them what's everyone been
asking you today what was it like on the
Bond movie they were really interested
in that because I was quite young when I
did the Star Wars and that was a you
know as a big excitement for me as well
because it was the third in the trilogy
at that time so it's like gosh you know
so those are the questions little bit
about the celebrity about who did you
meet Roger more people like that on wild
geese which was it was the very first
thing I ever did how did it compare like
something like wild geese who later in
your career I really enjoy wild goose
because it was whereas the other the
other sort of main movies like the bond
and the Star Wars I mean literally I was
on the Star Wars for a day I mean they
paid fantastically well I've got to say
that about George Lucas is it I think I
bought an entire apartment out of that
that's right and then doing the wild
geese which was an amazing kind of
learning curve I was on that for 12
weeks yeah so it's a it's quite a
different thing I think we style wasn't
unit good sort of it's very focused and
in fact completely I mean couldn't be
more different than the other one
because it was very dark the set was
incredibly dark I mean they almost had
to turn the lights on to see where you
were walking because it was so moody you
know so that was a that was something
you like being part it's like to map
their franchises of both Star Wars and
bombs why do you think why do you think
they are still so big now people love
them so much but they're great stories
aren't they and their adventures yeah
and there the modern their Monday
parables are they for people and it
people get so caught up in it fantastic
it's absolutely fantastic there were you
a fan of them so we seen you in third
always I mean my father's very friendly
with Sean Connery and so we knew him as
when we were growing up so it's slightly
demystified in a way but still even even
though you know him very personally and
my father was an actor so we lived in a
theatrical family so there were
characters as well as you know the real
real people it's something like Living
Daylights I mean what was it like
working on that
it's wonderful actually I mean they're a
real family the bombs people Barbara and
everybody there and they look after you
from the moment that you sign up right
the way through to the premiere and
everything and it's it's exciting
because all of those people on those
Bond movies particularly there were a
few crossovers of technicians I met who
were on the Star Wars and of course on
the on the wild geese and it's it's very
kind of fun how are you great how's it
going you know theatrically interesting
you know nice and very family-like
what was it you particularly enjoyed
about working on Star Wars but it was as
you said was a day but it sounds quite
intense in a way it is I mean you know
at that time I guess I was I was very
young as 22 think maybe 20 if that and
the impact of the first two I mean they
were just huge right they I mean they
were the biggest things on the planet at
that time and then getting cast in it
you just think wonder I have no idea
what the what the role was until you
turn up I mean I would have been very
happy to have played we do something
with the helmet on I just have got to
seen it you know and it was a day
getting prepared we do all the costume
fittings and all of that Elstree and
then the scene was we did I think we did
three scenes one remains in it I think
two were cut but they're now on the on
the blu-ray
it was a fantastic experience very dark
rooms seriously professionally quite
quiet the same there wasn't a lot of
banter
they were very focused because I think
that what they were doing technically
was really quite hard
I think the lighting and that kind of
thing was really cute
eh it was incredibly dark so you saw
that you sort of be in the darkness with
people who torches
you know coming up and whispering to you
and then suddenly a kind of a couple of
lights would go on and it was so it was
a bit like being on the desktop yeah I
guess it was really exciting
and finally what do you think about
because obviously Star Wars coming back
episodes 7 8 and 9 and then also bond
the 50th year as well that's just yes
bill that's right I mean I see Barbara
from time to time at Pinewood and I I'm
not really acting anymore I mean I'm
here doing this but
hello - still alive here because he only
gets sort of shot with a paint palette
most of the other bomb Oh double Oh guys
recut it's like a grisly end but yes and
there's always an option it's come back
as BOSU my old age are you looking
forward to seeing the new Star Wars
cause when they're eventually made in
Italy and I die I live quite near
Pinewood and they've shifted they'll be
doing than been there everyone since we
I'm even sort of uh saw it on the news
the other day George Osborne talking
about it and it's a massive thing isn't
it
and now that Disney's got it I'm sure
they'll do they'll take it on another
stage right they they'll go do something
they'll want to put their mark on it
fantastic
oh you've got a love Disney
you